the Sigmund a mini SUV segment is
becoming increasingly competitive
explains our car expert on show with
seeit Sirona and the hyundai kona
already in the ring this year sees
volkswagen launching the Polo T cross
the Renault Cup tour has already been
around for four years but due to the
growing number of rivals has been given
a makeover
[Music]
Renault was quick to notice the trend
towards subcompact SUVs it brought out
the cup tour back in 2013 with a bullish
look and high seats it had just a little
bit more car than as usual with sub
compacts and it proved popular with
drivers in various parts of the world
instead of taking on the likes of the
Tiguan
Renault decided to move down two
categories to enter the fray but since
then the cup tour has perhaps been
overtaken by contemporary expectations
[Music]
and you doesn't find the cup tour very
fun to drive that's partly because the
suspension hasn't been upgraded you feel
every little bump in the road and around
fast bends the car really sways a lot
[Music]
at first glance the cup tour doesn't
seem to have changed much the side
profile still looks as if it were
drawing its belly in and apart from the
LED lamps there's little excitement at
the rear
but at least the face itself got a lift
the radiator grille in front apron have
adopted the style of their Big Brother
the kadjar giving the cup tour a fresher
complexion the new daytime running
lights in the full LED headlamps also
contribute to a more youthful appearance
the trunk can accommodate 377 litres of
cargo or 1,200 35 litres with the seats
down rear passengers have sufficient
legroom the facelift has not resulted in
any technical revelations report stuns
you Renault focus solely on the things
that you can see and feel but the
engines are the same the choice is still
between the two gasoline and two diesel
units covering an output range from 66
to 87 kilowatts the diesel engine in our
test car generates 81 kilowatts of power
with a peak torque of 260 newton-meters
and makes the dash to 100 km/h in 11.4
seconds on the transmission front the
only option is a manual 6-speed
transmission driving the front wheel
drive cup tour at a moderate pace
however does pay off
official economy is just 3.7 liters of
fuel for 100 kilometers
[Music]
don't you finds the response especially
in the first three speeds truly accident
shift further up however and it can
start to splutter as for the interior
the makeover was long overdue renault
has responded by replacing the cheap
plastic finishes with piano black
inserts and chrome embellishments and
all equipment lines
Renault's infotainment system is clearly
organized and easy to operate on the
offroad front however the rework cup
tour has not made any significant
advances there is still no all-wheel
drive or electronic traction assist
available for challenging terrain its
popularity to date made to a major
degree be down to its charm and allure
and the lack of credible rivals until
recently with the intense competition
tanja finds the cap to his facelift
remarkably limited the most conspicuous
changes are some new colors and improved
interior and a blind spot monitor he
feels the suspension could have deserved
a reworking too but at least the prices
are reasonable and apply the fail and in
Germany they start at 17,000 euros for
the entry-level model
you
[Applause]